percebendo que acho que acusava para o
cantor notícia de uma discussão que é
excelente que a gente repete do dia que
é a mudança que o mundo
a velocidade da mudança em que o mundo
anos estabelece que todos os dias eu
viro uma boa parte a maior parte da vida
delas mais sozinho
eu fui até a universidade mais gente lá
são 25 anos já vem de uma instituição
formadora uma incisão de professores me
ensina e também fez vários cursos fazer
minha vida dentro desse contexto tive a
oportunidade também de atuar dentro de
instituições de formação básica educação
infantil anos iniciais do ensino médio
quando você decide ser professor
você também decide dividir a vida com
uma vida das pessoas
quando você toma uma decisão de que você
vai ser professora
assim juntamente com essa decisão você
decidiu também que a tua vida não é só a
tua que o comprometimento do seu
trabalho envolve tantas outras pessoas
então você precisa casar no dia você
precisa estudar sempre e quando a gente
está sempre a gente encontra respostas
ea cada resposta que a gente encontra
três ou quatro perguntas também fazem
parte dessa conquista da vaga para o
cliente uma resposta e acaba sendo
contemplado com mais preto no processo e
algumas duram para sempre
em uma delas que é objeto da minha da
minha experiência à equipe admitiu que
vocês a partir de agora acompanhar
a vida que é quem é um professor o que é
ser um bom professor
qual é o papel do professor e aí você
começa a analisar mais um professor
prático do que pra que né
qual é o papel da escola ao longo do
tempo a gente percebeu que a escola
infelizmente ao longo da história da
nossa da nossa civilização
neste campeonato brasileiro nós
prestamos a tendência exigências da
produção para a lateral
lá no período pós que é um título vagas
ainda na primeira movimentação de trazer
indústrias para para o brasil então lado
compara a necessidade também da formação
da mão de obra especializada para
atender a essa nova fase a escola da
empresa um diretor no super professor
orientador um encarregado que as
máquinas distribuídas uma forma de linha
de produção que agrediu fatores e
padrões da produção industrial ea escola
se organizou com as carteiras
distribuídas uma hora para a outra
armando ferreira diretor do supervisor é
um educador professor de escola buscava
resultados metas a escola precisava
atingir determinadas nos resultados
um dos principais pontos naquele período
era professor no papel de quem sabe que
domina um conhecimento muito claro muito
claro ao canal do valo não sabe quando
nem tem conhecimento ele estava prender
ou soltar a pressionar o aluno tem sente
inclinado tem que cumprir suas tarefas e
tentava a esposa para prender o tempo
todo é exatamente aquilo que se estava
nas indústrias e nas empresas de mercado
dos usados
funcionários obedientes disciplinados
que estivessem dispostas por resultados
na década de 60 na tomada do poder
brasil pela ditadura militar no brasil
51 deu de uma forma bastante
significativa com os modelos de produção
americana e no modelo taylor está forte
está se estabelecendo no brasil um
grande símbolo melo ea escola se
organizou de novo para realizarem acções
nacionais em cada uma dessas empresas
e aí o método como fazer passou o papel
da escola professor aquele que ensina o
aluno a fazer um bom jogo
esse período é o que conseguiu esse
resultado as escolas criaram educação
profissionalizante talvez alguns lembram
ensino médio chapa 14 anos você aprende
a ser técnico em contabilidade é com a
educação para o ar é mais externo e
outros então com 14 anos já se preparava
o indivíduo para ocupar o espaço de
comentários do trabalho quer ser o papel
do professor na década de 80 com a
falência do regime militar
ele não se estabeleceu além de 82 não o
retorno dos intelectuais que iria
selados quando nosso país nesse período
o céu pra cá uma discussão foram os
ligados à educação
os filósofos franceses educadores
tiveram uma influência muito grande no
sistema educacional nosso país tem
escola se posicionou política crítica à
crítica social dos conteúdos 09
então a escola é um lugar político onde
se discutiam sindical e se posicionavam
sobre as coisas da nossa
a sociedade em que vivemos uma década e
pouco sem conteúdo
basicamente a escola focada numa questão
política é crítica a partir de 90 a
velocidade duas vezes e produção da
capital avançado foi infinitamente
superior à capacidade da escola que a
instituição de ensino tem de acompanhar
a escola ficou para trás
a escola passa a correr atrás desse
modelo a partir daí a partir do ano 2000
então nós temos assim um outro contexto
é a outra realidade
a pergunta de novo aqui a ouvir isso
alguns já me responder por clt que
ensina e vejo eu descobri que você não
tem capacidade para ensinar só quando
você quer sentar na frente do professor
durante o semestre inteiro sem perder
nenhuma aula enquanto transmitir o
conhecimento literalmente eu fico
imaginando como seria legal se fosse
todo mundo concentrado vamos lá
o poder é anormal e transmitiu uma
discussão da relação dos meios de
produção com o papel do professor de
hoje nós falamos muito sobre a
organização do trabalho uma pessoa que
não tem o poder de ensino o professor
faz a gestão que propõe situações de
aprendizagem onde o aluno não aprendeu
quando que as possibilidades que na
proposta
significa aluno as chances de que ela
não queira por nenê
naquela propostas são muito maiores
quanto mais uma pessoa atende às
necessidades daqueles alunos plano
propõe uma situação sua loja virtual
hoje no mundo as informações chegam a
uma velocidade maior que a capacidade do
próprio professor tenha como uma forma
professores profissionais e tecnológico
moderno ele fez com que a escola mas a
escola não vai alcançar os lugares todos
os passos e é preciso refletir então
olha o nosso papel como nós vamos
promover essa vontade de aprender para
poder procurar as melhores em alguns
conceitos e teorias da própria
administração respostas
hoje é preciso planejar a ser professor
não é uma coisa artesanato
se você tem um tom fitton então não vejo
algumas facilidades que me favorece
é preciso profissionalizar o trabalho de
planejar planejar com base no conteúdo
quando a escada está implementado para
aquele momento
tudo isso é planejado eu tenho que levar
em consideração a onde eu quero chegar
com isso quem são esses alunos o que
querem estes alunos
então o papel do professor hoje o bom
professor é aquele que faz a gestão do
processo de ensino aprendizagem
isso não é artesanal isso não é
intuitivo
isso não é um dom isso é uma preparação
profissional extremamente específica
para que você consiga realmente
desempenhar esse papel pode dizer que o
partido tem muitos congressos e ouvia um
tempo atrás uma coisa que me incomodava
quando uma professora disse no congresso
vai chegar um dia em que nós não vamos
mais ensinar as crianças a escrever ela
não precisa escrever ea gente até a ilha
pesava 10 ela não sabe que neste país a
maioria sequer têm contador conhece um
computador ea gente imaginava isso no
futuro talvez a gente nem fosse viver aí
eu pergunto se passaram dez anos eu
pergunto pra vocês agora
rascunhos e se escolheu o que é preciso
fazer da minha vida
se a partir de hoje o sistema
educacional e solicitar a formação
inicial seus atos
a competência de se ensinar a escrever
com uma caneta no papel
qual é a falta é fazer
vejo a velocidade da ativa que é um
absurdo um tempo atrás ela já chegou e
já passou
eu desafio porque eu fiz essa pergunta
depois de bola e não consegui parar de
pensar nisso mas eu queria comprar por
isso queria na verdade um argumento
forte para poder voltar e se assim
pensei como e por que precisa ser esse é
o mundo do qual nós formamos os falsos
pessoas é esse mundo do qual nós
precisamos nos capacitar para poder
entrar na sala de aulas do grupo de
alunos de propor situações de
aprendizagem
então infelizmente é a formação de
professores hoje ela ainda carece muito
tite que isso seja um objeto de grandes
profissionais ainda têm a possibilidade
de ter hoje na sala de aula
profissionais formados necessário para
ser professor em algumas áreas técnicas
do bacharel por exemplo o professor é
contratado e ele recebe um jaleco e
muitos deles disse pronto agora sou
professor então estudar e entender as
relações humanas baseadas numa palavra
que é símbolo dessa discussão eu quero
você dança significado professores
entendem o significado daquilo que faz
é preciso entender qual é o caso da
proposta de ensino aprendizagem que lhe
trouxe
é o que é relevante para os nossos
alunos hoje tudo é relevante na formação
de professores
então eu me pego nos 50 anos com quase
30 anos de faculdade
ainda para a mesma pergunta quem é
alguma pessoa como se estabelece uma
pessoa
então hoje a gente discute muito essa
questão de quem é o aluno de tallil
declarando que é o que ela precisa
descobrimos que os nossos alunos quando
vêm para cá eles acabam carregando mas
acaba levando consigo muitas das coisas
que os seus professores pensam vem e
acreditar né
hoje eu quis dividir com vocês essa
intenção porque a formação do
profissional da educação superior
ele começa
chega nesta sessão se há aqueles
objetivos de lá atrás de disciplina a
objetivos de comportamento e de atitude
eles se transformarão mas eles não
sairão daqui hoje é preciso é necessário
que alguém quando vê um profissional de
sucesso você tem a oportunidade de ver
que você se coloca nessa situação
imagine qual é o caminho para chegar lá
e nós vamos descobrir o caminho o ponto
de partida ficou para trás
é preciso retomar mais em caminho então
quando começa a preparar o primeiro dia
que você chegou à universidade a tua
postura a tua atitude a tua relação com
tudo que você vai viver aqui dentro tem
que ser diferente
você tem que se posicionar de forma
diferenciada
hoje nós temos ainda o aluno de sentar
numa cadeira antes me ensine autismo que
ensinou é o papel do professor hoje a
gente não é a de ensinar nenhum de vocês
não é o papel do professor
o papel do professor é gerenciar um
processo ao vovô ses vão ser os atores
principais desse processo
o resultado do que vocês vão conseguir
aqui é exatamente proporcional ao
empenho ea dedicação de vocês vão
colocar dentro desse processo então o
papel de informação hoje que os alunos
não é mais do professor
o papel do professor é pros proporção
nas situações onde cada um de vocês vai
aprender a fazer a gestão tem esse
conhecimento e decide onde vocês querem
chegar e como vão chegar e os fracassos
do mercado de trabalho estão
relacionados com o tempo em que o
universitário leva para descobrir isso
exatamente isso
são momentos como esse são aqueles em
que os anúncios que ouvi
e ouviu aqui são nesses momentos que
eles começam a colocar sua carreira numa
outra velocidade tão importante que todo
mundo entenda que o papel de uma pessoa
hoje ele não está mais no centro está o
apoio ea figura principal de uma
universidade são os seus alunos né
então quero dedicar essa sandice bate
papo aqui os alunos que estão dividindo
comigo se ter bin e agradecer pela
atenção para realizar nossos colegas
daqui ainda um olhar
[Aplausos]